Вбрання не обов’язково купувати.
Його можна позичити на якийсь час.
У цьому гамбурзькому закладі
це можливо. Його концепція -
щось на кшталт бібліотеки для одягу,
так звана одяготека.
Шопінг без докорів сумління.
Клієнтки в захваті.
Приміром, я позичила пальто,
а також спідницю. Я тут уперше,
і мені страшенно подобається.
Це далекоглядно, без марних витрат.
Як на мене, круто!
Це супер, слід ще більше такого робити.
Випробувати це, так би мовити, "наживо"
можна ще вісім тижнів.
Після цього одяготека існуватиме лише в інтернеті.
За абонплату - 49 євро на місяць -
клієнткам присилатимуть поштою
чотири різні вбрання, які вони можуть носити
впродовж чотирьох тижнів.
Для засновниць  це більше, ніж просто бізнес-ідея.
Наша велика, кітчева, але основоположна ідея
полягає в тому, що споживання загалом мусить,
повинно і може докорінно змінитися.
І ми нашою ідеєю робимо свій внесок у це.
Майже 2000 предметів одягу налічує одяготека.
Їх беруть зі стоків чи секонд-хенду
або ж позичають знайомі та й самі клієнтки.
П'ятеро співробітниць займаються підбором
вбрання, розсилкою та перевіркою
поверненого одягу. При цьому вдається
ще й заробити. Асортимент
та коло задоволених клієнток постійно  збільшуються.